on this episode we just rocked out
episode 182
[Music]
this
[Music]
everybody it's gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is a one eighty two of the ask gary
vee show we're a little bit of a role
it's just like this three actual
business days in a row Thursday Friday
Monday a lot of people off on this
present day Monday not vaynermedia I'm
not sure they're super pumped about that
but like like it's weird like I don't
think this is should be a day off
I got like presents and everything but
like I don't know like it's something
I've never taken off and I always do say
everything stems from the top so but
we've started adding more and more
actual official vacation days here
veiners we've grown up you still only be
like Christmas you better be on January
1st
alright Indians good to see you I'm
gonna interesting mellow Sirius modem
very in a serious mode are you okay
alright go ahead go ahead well actually
you should ask the first question cuz I
don't wanna spend on a India's food is
here she'll be right there she'll be
right there
alright Christopher are asks Gary have
you ever dropped the ball on making a
decision due to overthinking it Chris
Chris I would say that um my I almost
need her to repeat it but I think I got
it actually I sent it to her so I got it
some I got it
the reason I sent it to India was I saw
this Chris in the feed is I'm actually
normally making mistakes in the other
direction so I tend not to overthink at
all I'm very intuitive and most of my
business mistakes have been to act too
quickly and then have to bail out i I've
found that speed trumps everything and
so for me when I weigh opportunity costs
I'd rather start something both money
and time if I intuitively feel it and
then let it fail six months or a year
later new concepts I have for Vayner new
divisions new types of wines for Wine
Library thinks I've done for my own
brand I and I want to push so many of
you for this I really want to push a lot
of you so many of you are not taking
action because you overthink it you
overthink it you overthink it I always
say deploy your resources that you can
afford to lose
a lot of you don't have the dollars I
used to not have the dollars but I had
my time the reason I hunted my 20s was
cuz I didn't have money or I didn't have
a lot of it you know a lot of you hear
about the three million dollar business
I love them people like try to rag on me
and so knowing if everybody had three
million dollar business I mean every
single kid that gets five hundred
thousand dollars and startup which was
millions had more dollar resources than
I had even have dollars business did
three million dollars
it made three hundred thousand dollars
in profit and selling three million
dollars worth of liquor and then it's
still how to pay expenses and my dad
took home his salary like we had no
money
but I had my time and I would test
things and I stayed up I didn't pump my
twenties for kicks and giggles I punted
them because the only resource I had was
my time and so I had to work 18 hours a
day because it's when I had got it so
taking action is especially if it
doesn't cost you top money and it's just
time is always a better answer than
pondering or thinking or trying to
decide if this is gonna work you don't
know the learning of the failure is as
equal to the victory of it right the
learning the things I've learned in my
20 years but we some so advanced as a
business person in my own mind is not
only have I worked a lot but I've you
know this work hard work smart thing I
worked smart and one of the smartest
things I do as an entrepreneur and a
business person is I do things so I can
understand whether they work or not they
can't just sit here and say is this
gonna work or not debating it your whole
life never do it and then not know the
answer like you know like one of two
great things happen one you did it and
it worked and you make money and you won
and you got accolades and it worked
Wine Library TV it worked the Wine
Library the classes that I was gonna do
or try to think of things that fail it's
like you know another thing is I just
forget them so quickly I'll work on this
oh you know India I want to do like top
eleven things I did at Wine Library that
didn't work local van delivery at scale
I never did you know so like so so one
of two things happen either it works and
you make money the email service it
worked or it
and you're like well I'm not gonna do
that again but this whole like
indecisiveness when you can do it if you
own the money you can't do it so are you
thinking about it for you know I wonder
if I buy a building in New York City
will it go up in value I wonder
the answer is it's gonna work but guess
what I don't have four hundred million
dollars liquid to buy an empire state
building type building because he can't
even buy that for four thousand you know
400 million you know so like this is
this is an interesting question the
answer's no I've never failed because of
indecisiveness
I've only failed cuz I've done stuff but
I'd argue that I didn't really fail I
learned I might have Micro failed but I
macro one J Scott asks Gary do you
expect your own employees to work like
you do does it affect your opinion of
them J do not expect any of my employees
to work as hard as I do because it's not
their business and I get so mad at so
many of you that get mad at employees
that don't work as hard as you they
shouldn't like why in the world would
they now there's plenty employees here
that know that I value hard work and
hustle and they know they'll be rewarded
within the context but no I do not
expect anybody to work harder than me
and I think one of the quickest ways for
a business to fail is to have an
employee working harder than you and let
me break that down so many of you think
you make it and then you get the chill
and then what you expect everybody
underneath you to work hard to sustain
nobody cares that you work your ass off
for fifteen years to get to this point
they know that you're failing right now
and like fishing and like like hanging
out with your boyfriend on the beach for
a month and you're supposed to hold it
up why because they worked hard for 15
years what about them people have their
own vested interests and if you're not
out working them and you know so in fact
never like I have to work so hard to
create an infrastructure that can allow
me to even have the audacity to have
people to want to work with me for a
long time the only way I can even expect
all of them to work with me for a long
time like I want them to is that I
create such a big thing that they can
make the monies and have the challenges
both get the monetary values they
the work-life balance and the money they
want to take home and do things that are
interesting and creative and challenging
and not the same thing the only way I
can do that is to build the biggest
thing possible which means I have to
outwork them to have the to have that
wants and needs an audacity to have
people to work for me
talented people to work for me people
that can really move the needle so no it
doesn't change my opinion as a matter of
fact I'm hope and I know a lot of you
are watching right now at Vayner I hope
that I'm creating something that allows
hundreds of them to have a 9:00 to 6:00
not 9:00 to 5:00 a 9:00 to you know a
9:00 to 6:00 4550 our kind of job that
pays them enough to be happy and gives
them plenty of hours to be on the
bowling team or knit or work on their
music on the side or come home for
dinner every night like like no I do not
judge them because if they wanted to be
exactly like me or if they want wired
like me or had the ambition like me or
the talent like me they'd be doing it
for themselves as they should and I want
that for them yeah I'm good yosef hi
Gary here's Joseph recent they were
complaining that you are not receiving
enough question from us so here is one
from the heart of Europe the city of
Prague my question is about recruitment
LinkedIn is currently standard for
recruitment how do you recruit our
people and is LinkedIn the crucial
my article says trust of thank you for
the question and by the way that's just
excited me more video questions with
awesome backgrounds from all over
different places something that's
signature you know like if you live in
your Mount Rushmore would love one of
those anybody in your Mount Rushmore
I'll take it as are you getting ready
for your summer vacations as you get
around more visually exciting things for
askgaryvee you will get on the show we
use LinkedIn hard we even pay for the
program it's a great utility it works
great for Vayner but nothing works
better than the brand when you build
something that's special people are
coming to you instead of you recruiting
the greatest way to recruit is to not
recruit it's to do something that is so
significant or interesting or curious or
challenging that people want to work for
you
veiners now starting to get that
momentum even though i don't promote it
this is me holding off promotion even
though I don't promote if you're
wondering if you know I don't promote it
what we are doing is we're trying to let
the word of mouth or the people that try
hard enough to like get through all the
traps I put out there to get through and
see what's actually going on here and so
I would say you linked it is a great
tool for us we love it we use it we're
we're we use it a lot but the word of
mouth of the internal employees telling
other people they should come and work
here oh my god this is amazing place and
people that are sniffing out and talking
to other people clients or human beings
my clients are human beings meaning when
they know they're getting great work and
they're out to dinner with a buddy who
happened to work at an agency that's a
competitor and like you know we should
really look at Vayner any clients we cut
a leg employees we get that way what a
mouth so the two ways to do it is to do
great stuff that everybody wants to work
for you and I do think the utility of
lengthen is great I think Twitter search
is incredible as well I got a surprise
for you guys pop let's go I like this
part so tall good to see you so tall
way too tall no I'm not way too tall I
love it sit all right man donation is a
lot of fun for a lot of you that have
been following this story this is an
incredibly interesting moment for many
of them a lot of them that haven't been
usable right well thank you but for many
of them who
not heard the story I'll give you a
minute to give the background of how
you're sitting here right now - for us
many of you know me already from in the
hitch-hiker Vancouver - New York City
trouble called money just hitchhike all
the way to New York City to get on the
show which happens right now so what day
did you announce - we're on what social
platform and where did you announce I am
in Vancouver and I'm gonna hitchhike to
New York with no money to be on the
askgaryvee show it's not it on Facebook
and then I went to Instagram and Twitter
we're both quite a fanbase a lot of
people support and what day did you
start this journey on the 3rd of January
3rd runs and what was going on on
January 2nd through your mind I'm
generally saying i was meditation but
meditating in a meditation camp
interesting and I was what I asked
anything like it was just chilling my
just check yep end of row and then the
next day I started the trip and was
exciting and how long have you been
watching this show mmm I'd say around a
year got it but not like every episode
yep but saying the last in the Indus
month where was traveling then it should
really much into it yes it was like yeah
of course
and so what happened you started man
Coover and the game plan was I'm gonna
get to New York on the back of people's
kindness as how I've recited from afar
but I didn't spend any money so it was
completely on the kindness of strangers
and I didn't ask anyone for food on the
whole trip it was always from them so I
told them about the trip what I gonna do
so before we get to you asking me a
question for the show
what about a little work on my interview
skills what about what about what was
the strangest and funniest what about
the strangest and funniest thing that
happened on the trip it is strange thing
was I was meeting a guy who was in
prison for attempted murderer for 16
years and I was in it yeah I was in his
car and then you told me so I was in
there already
let's take a step back you go into a
stranger's car right and you're telling
me you're in this man's car right
and you're just shooting the [ __ ] right
and he says oh yeah I was in prison for
16 years on the captain burner when I
asked you like what are you up to
lo'laan he's like I just come out of
prison attempts morosely that's my house
that's not good pretty scary yes and
yeah he was a nice guy I was sitting in
the backseat and yet like this tool is
like that's not good
thought she was a good know what about
the funniest mmm or some other anecdote
like who anybody really interesting or
he didn't do anything fun did anybody
cook you like a seven-course meal or
like anything so much good food I was I
was invited for rump steak Thai food
Vietnamese what I was eating them better
than I like food wise we thought was
been spending and not spending money
and so what about so we met some of you
saw our interaction for the first time
on dailyvee a couple episodes ago when
we were walking it didn't make footage
you you told me a little bit about your
background you're an entrepreneur in
Germany right yeah it's not an
intrapreneur very early like around five
or six Senate floors just as you as I
told you and after 13 corporate jobs I
said to myself I'm not ever going to
work for anyone else but with someone
else and of the public company we live
in Korea a financial company and we sell
furniture and so how much how much are
you staying in the States
um just what we's opening back right
back to Germany a peg on the clock
good trip look commander what's your
question before some questions yes thank
you to everyone what we saw because you
want to people you want to give out some
names couple shout outs right what I
want to do I'm gonna go for that I you
should want to give back I want to
support you as well I go to buy eight of
those books I want to give two away to
Ken mark and Jesse Russell's who support
me and they're off the mana nation love
it and six I want to give away to
everyone who is sharing this video I
will pick six and sent them a coffee
very nice now are you at but what
happens if I pull your name from the
receipt pool on the 23rd you're gonna
give that away I thought about giving it
to way to anyone but I would give it
away to my business partner Joe let's
respect very good sense to me very good
I guess in London right cuz that's a
quicker trip then in whatever makes it
alright so what's the question was over
the last month yes I realize for myself
and consuming way too much content yes
whether yours or Ferris Flynn whoever
yes and I'm Way too much to execute on
so I decided not to ask a typical of
askgaryvee question okay we'll be
consuming again okay
and that go of the most practical one I
could think of which is are you in
president having me as an intern for a
period of one month and one year from
now and to make it harder for me and
more interesting to you only if by then
I executed on the advice you gave me on
dailyvee to publish a book about this
trip done super simple if you didn't
follow that because it's a good accent
but I can hear and I don't know how good
your audio is dirac you're gonna come
back in a year an intern at vaynermedia
for a month but only if you actually
write a book about publishing if you
publish a book of a very good job if you
publish a book on what I told you also
didn't make the screen I'm like look you
need to write a book oh it didn't make
the screen got it I don't watch my own
stuff though I did watch 14d Rock you
crush that yeah it's 100 percent cool
alright brother thank you something like
I'll say bye I've turned over the show
alright um that was fun super cool right
yeah this is a good episode you're right
in here
did a great job set out made it happen
kind of cool
yeah let's move on yeah let's do two
more since he didn't ask a question
statement Gary Vee hashtag statement
Gary Vee actually it was really he was
growth hacking he was trying to make his
[ __ ] happen I respect the hustle let's
go
Tammy asks Gary what brings you peace
there is such fun in the hustle sure but
what brings the comedies for you that's
a very interesting question I should
nice pic there India um you know what I
think that I'm very basic I I really
want the people I care about to be
healthy I truly truly you know what's
really sad for me and I'll share this is
getting to be one of the deeper episodes
I think I was gonna be really surprised
by how I act when something bad happens
in my life I'm I really don't care about
all this like really don't like way way
more than you think
like my ability to not give up about
buying New York Jets is so much greater
than you think
I think that when I completely disappear
for nine weeks or a year or whatever it
is I think you know I think this moment
will get clipped and shared a lot
hopefully in 50 years but whenever that
time comes when the first tragic illness
and/or death in my family happens you
will not see I don't think listen the
truth is I've never dealt with it maybe
I maybe I rely on you even more maybe
I'm on more than ever because it's my
outlet but I have a funny feeling one
thing I know I don't care about book
sales or wine sales or vaynermedia
clients so what gives me pieces that I
know who I am
I really know who I am that's what
really gives me peace India I'm really
in tuned Who I am my self-awareness is
way off the charts
like I just Know Who I am I know who how
I roll I know what I care about I know
that I care I had a fan like tell
another fan recently like I don't watch
care of you anymore just imposing his
hustle like all he wants to impose is
that he he out works all of us like it
bothers me because it makes me sad that
I'm not doing a good enough job
balancing that that person believes that
to be true but I know exactly what I'm
doing I also know that the tweet word he
made fun of me the next tweet he did a
snapchat post with the five steps to how
to follow him on snapchat which is a
complete replica of the way I did it
that's called following tactical advice
so you know I I Know Who I am through
and through and so I'm at global peace
always because I know who I am I know
what my tent is and I know on providing
value and I know that even in when I'm
in bookselling mood when I'm asking and
I'm throwing right hooks that I'm always
providing more value than I'm asking for
in return that I'm asking for I might be
getting more value somebody may buy 500
books and I've given them 400 books
worth of value but I'm never asking for
more value in return than I'm giving
ever and that gives me an enormous piece
I think I'm whole with everybody people
that know me the best no I'm most
uncomfortable if I'm not whole with them
I spend my whole [ __ ] 20 should get
in hole with my parents
nope a daisy a daisy or a daisy got it I
thought a daisy actually like made the
show it's like sorry mother nature I do
love you
these things are talking to me this is
weird yes hey Gary how you doin
my name is a daisy and our producer some
way two artists from Barbados and I've
been asking this question will I keep a
chicken if you're an artist manager it
was something you would have your
artists do that artists right now aren't
leveraging so something completely
different out of the box
thanks a lot Daisy first of all you're a
cooler [ __ ] I would probably be focused
on musically I'm fascinated by musically
right now it's a social network that's
emerging it's around music and I think
that if you're an artist and you're
doing creative on top of your own music
and then reaching out to other people so
let me actually break this down very
tactically because it can lead to what
musicians can be doing a musically
article which I'd love to get out there
because I think musically is absolutely
at least already in Yik yak territory
where it's like really got my attention
musically is an app that reminds me of
like dubsmash where a lot of people do
lip syncing but you can also do vine and
Instagram videos behind music because
they figured out the music rights or I
don't know what how it's actually
working but I know these days you
couldn't get them up
there probably in terms of service of
how much you can sample did it anyway if
I was a musician I would try and put out
content on top of my own music but that
may not pop because your musics not as
popular as all the other music but what
I would do is start reaching out to
other influencers in that community one
of the best ways to reach out to people
in a community is to become part of the
community like you can't go to Reddit
and spam everybody but if you actually
read and engaged and commented and
shared and we're part of Reddit for two
years you've bought permission to throw
your right hook I would become a major
major part of musically I would use my
own music and create content I would use
other people's music and create content
I would comment on the top hundred
people's content engage become a join
any you know even in Barbados I would
literally take all my money and fly by
the New Yorker
musically meetup you become part of the
new community and then you've got
permission to do things and so for me
that's what I would do I would
absolutely become part of the musically
community engage comment share create
and then do real-life things
engage with them and other networks
comment on their instagrams become don't
spam them don't greet them just become
part of it and then I really think you
have a chance of popping out because I
think if you think about it imagine if
you were doing this with line early on
and you got the 40 vigorous bynars to do
something with your music and mimin you
could really really hit it and then if
you're a musician you can actually write
a hook that's a round musically culture
like that 15-second flip you know like
you could like you know Jesus that was
weird but but you know like you could
actually integrate something that's
unique on on about musically in a song
that then people would use you know
holding a Dalek snapchat you know like
you know like like that kind of stuff
back with snapchat yeah to hold it down
you see where I'm going
it was a good show it was a really
really rock solid show yeah question a
day how many books are gonna buy you
keep asking questions I'll keep
answering them
[Music]